area winter has revealed she is off to
college we caught up with the Modern
Family star about her big news at the
shows any consideration event how did
you make that decision ultimately what
was it like when you got the acceptance
letter tell me everything it was amazing
you know I love UCLA everyone my family
loves UCLA it's an amazing school the
college process was I have to say so
long and just really really insane but
at the end of the day I'm so happy with
UCLA when I got the acceptance letter I
literally just that and cried staring at
my computer everything winter will
continue acting she's growing up and
that means trying new things you have
this great style and you're trying all
sorts of different looks where's that
confidence coming from I think that you
screw over time honestly you know I've
been through a roller coaster with
myself definitely growing up from the
public eye but I think now as I've
gotten older and you know I've had so
many people around me learn help me
learn to accept myself and that's been
really amazing for me it's a journey for
everybody to find a way to be able to
love themselves completely and never be
insecure and I if there are people like
that then literally I've added them
that's what I you know want to be in the
future she's humble but her
self-confidence is evident winter posts
bikini pics for her nearly 2 million
Instagram followers to see how do you
pick the photos that it's what goes
through your head when you're like I'm
gonna put this on social media
there's a lot of people follow you
really I'm just posting having phoned my
boyfriend my family my friends just
really doing anything in my life I love
to share everything because I know
people that follow me like to see what's
going on I love to share it with them
her boyfriend does seem like he's an
amazing support system for you what does
his support mean we've been together for
three years infinite three years he's
always been so supportive so loving and
he's really helped me build up my
confidence as well and I'm just really
grateful